[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
kate andrews economics correspondent at
the spectator
and jonathan list deputy director of
british
influence good evening to you both so
let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now one
last heave to freedom the telegraph says
boris johnson is to delay the june the
21st final end to lockdown
by four weeks asking the public to be
patient
in the face of a surge in covet cases
the time says the delay was signed off
by the prime minister tonight
and will be announced tomorrow
not what we wanted to hear of course but
the guardian says it will at least keep
thousands of people
out of hospital the mail contrasts the
agony of delaying the unlocked date with
the ecstasy of england's footballers
winning their first game at the euros
the eye claims an exclusive with news
that uk scientists will soon be able to
alter
covert 19 vaccines in just a matter of
weeks to combat
emerging new variants of the disease
show some respect as the metro's lead
with the foreign secretary's warning to
the french president
over his remarks about the so-called
sausage war with the eu
the financial times also leads with the
summit and says president biden used it
to rally his allies to the struggle
against what he called
the autocrats of china
the sun hails raheem sterling for his
winning gold for england against croatia
today his newly awarded mbe
standing for magic boots of england
and we're joined tonight by kate andrews
economics correspondent of the spectator
and jonathan list deputy director
of british influence welcome to you both
good evening
let's start with the telegraph front
page and that
june the 21st delay freedom day
will no longer be freedom day that's
been much reported
as to whether it will be four weeks
later
um that hasn't been confirmed by number
10.
um kate you've had a look at this front
page for us
so it's bad news uh the road map which
was going according to plan looks like
it's now coming to a fairly
rapid halt and although number 10 are
waiting until tomorrow to confirm any of
the details it looks like the new
freedom date so to speak maybe the 19th
of july so four weeks after was
originally planned
there's talk of a potential break clause
halfway through but
i think most people suspect that this is
probably going to be closer to a
four-week delay
of course there's still many outstanding
questions about this delay when we get
to the end of the four weeks we're still
waiting on information about social
distancing
which was a decision that was being
taken outside of the road map of course
international travel looks like it may
be
more restricted this year than it was
last year when we didn't have a single
working vaccine
and i think the crucial thing tomorrow
is to what extent the prime minister can
actually lay out the criteria to the
public
about what data they're looking at and
what they want to see to make sure
restrictions
can lift when it comes to july because
you can definitely start to feel
simmering tensions that people want to
know what more needs to be done
if vaccines are the solution what do we
need to see in the data
there's lots of talk about second jabs
to deal with the delta variant
there's lots of talks about getting more
first jobs into arms but what is the
specific criteria
that is something that has been left out
of this whole conversation for 15 months
now
when it came to the tear system lock
down circuit breakers we know it's a
combination
of infections hospitalizations and
deaths but assuming for the next few
weeks we continue to see that break
in infections and hospitalizations what
more needs to be done or does anything
else need to be done
to make sure that we can restore our
freedoms uh and we could just tell you
just some breaking news that uh
government source tells us sky news that
uh ministers are expected to delay
lifting of covered regulations
for four weeks so uh some confirmation
there jonathan your reaction to that
well i think the most annoying thing and
frustrating thing about this
is just how foreseeable it was um i
wrote an article
um for byline times in february uh the
week after
the robot was announced uh you know
highlighting just some of the problems
the political problems um that johnson
had made for himself
in setting out a precise calendar for
reopening
uh we know that the virus doesn't
unfollow a timetable
and there was no uh public clamoring a
precise date so they could mark
on their calendars but instead johnson
sort of
gave precise dates he couldn't possibly
have known the time he said it was
irreversible
which again he couldn't possibly have
known and here we are in a state where
everyone has had the 21st of june
uh marked out quite concretely in their
minds so you know businesses had made
arrangements to reopen which they'll now
have to scale back
he might have made arrangements have a
quite large gatherings
which they might now have to postpone
and so all this
all this was um avoidable and we also
knew
um that the vaccines were not going to
be delivered
um such that everyone would have two
doses
by antiversation so even though the
delta variant
might have been somewhat unpredictable
based on what we knew in february
um we knew that the vaccine rollout was
not going to be completed
and that we'd have unvaccinated people
in nightclubs on the 21st
of june so clearly that was far too
early so not only
did he make a political and moral error
in setting out the dates when he could
have been much vaguer about general
aspirations
he also shouldn't should and could have
known about
um the the data which would have
precluded such a premature opening
uh and kate how accepting do you think
people will be
of that this unlocking not taking place
on on the the 21st the daily mail has
the the headline ecstasy
and agony obviously that there will be
disappointment but will people be
understanding of the reasons behind it
i suspect they will be if the prime
minister can
really lay out clearly what the criteria
is for lifting restrictions
so so far the public have been more than
compliant and actually quite happy to go
along with
many of these major restrictions on our
lives um all i think coming from a
very good point of view that wanting to
protect their parents their grandparents
and even strangers it was the right
thing to do at different points of the
year
to lock down and restrict ourselves to
save lives and
but now that everybody's parents if they
want to have been jabbed and
grandparents have been jabbed and it's
just the young
that are waiting on vaccines they're
going to be growing questions as to why
it really isn't okay
to get up to more kinds of activities so
i think the public is a lot more likely
to go along with it if boris johnson can
make really clear promises about what
he's looking for in that data but if it
turns out to be vague i think it's going
to become harder and harder
to stick by now i agree with jonathan
partially i think saying
anything is irreversible is very
politically challenging because you can
get yourself
into real trouble but once we discover
we didn't just have one but
multiple working vaccines with very high
efficacy higher than many people
ever suspected we would get i actually
think it did make sense for the prime
minister
to give people some hope if you believe
in these vaccines and that they work it
was
sensible to say here is the earliest
that we're going to
hope to do these things and i think the
prime minister's challenge tomorrow
is if he says i just want a few more
weeks to make sure we've broken that
link between infections and
hospitalizations
i think the public will be understanding
but if it's anything vaguer than that it
is going to be a real struggle because
if vaccines aren't the answer
then what is the answer if the
government doesn't have any kind of
comprehensive message for that
people are going to start getting very
frustrated jonathan as i said the
the mail contrasting uh the emotions of
people ecstasy and agony the good news
that uh
england won that uh first euros game
um and then to think that freedom day
will no longer be on june the 21st
yeah i think there's also a problem with
the phrasing of freedom day
um that you know we kind of almost like
a national holiday and i think it's no
coincidence by the way that last year
um the reopening took place on the
fourth of july
um so the government was quite clear
that that would be a kind of
independence day
um obviously you get people's hopes up
if you if you
have phrasing like this obviously we're
all very excited
to pick up our lives but we all none of
us wants to
uh go back into normal life this summer
only to go back into lockdown
in the autumn now of course and we have
a vaccination roll out as kate was
saying
but the problem with this variant is
it's so much more transmissible
than the old variant which is also so
much more transmissible than the
original
um strain of kovid and that it will find
people who are unvaccinated and as we
know there is some vaccine escape as
well so
you know it will not take very much uh
if cases keep rising as they do
the hospitals can to potentially become
overwhelmed or there to be some kind of
problem with the nhs so
i think people will be understanding but
johnson has made a rod for his own back
he's made backbenchers extremely angry
and he's also irritated people who like
his cake points out are very anxious
and frustrated they want to begin their
normal lives but they also want to do so
with safety let's move on to some of the
ecstasy though shall we in the in the
metro with the with the football
sterling start
for england kate
yes well as you were saying uh we really
do need some hope and
reading certainly did give them today uh
it was a spectacular
goal i believe it was his uh first one
in
in in this kind of tournament and um it
puts england on a very good path to
go in uh on friday into their next match
um
and you know it it brings back that
enthusiasm that
now feels like a lifetime ago but was
only several years ago when
when england actually was doing uh very
well um
and so you know i feel like a lot is now
hanging on this team but they
they served us very well today and it
was exciting to follow yeah
and jonathan um raheem sterling's newly
awarded mbe has been renamed as magic
boots for england
yeah i kind of i'm the kind of person
who gets into football roughly every two
years
when there's an international tournament
so i was watching earlier and yeah it's
it's one of those great things for
raleigh it felt
you know it did feel brilliant and and
you know there was confidence when we
could see
um a stadium a state wembley stadium uh
that had real-life people in it
and you do feel a kind of sense of
enthusiasm that things are moving in the
right direction
which makes it all the more important
and that we and stay on the right track
but of course it'll be
such a great morale boost if england
goes far into this tournament i was
thinking how my
earliest football memory was euro 96 and
how excited we all were about that so
hopefully we can go one step further
this time yeah let's hope they can go
all the way again jonathan for the
moment
thank you coming up
end of an era after 12 years israel has
a new government
one many believed could never come
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magnay and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
[Music]
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh
who were digging up the soil of their
dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone
they can't arrest everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikista from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle
[Music]
exchange of your recyclable to get a
[Music]
trade
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me kate
andrews and jonathan liss there they are
um let's uh we haven't got much time so
let's um quickly go
through the times front page there their
headline northern ireland around mars
final day of g7 kate do you believe that
it did i'm not sure it did actually i
think that the main story over the
course of the week
is more tax focus with the global
minimum corporation
tax and i also think the focus on joe
biden and his interaction with
world leaders but no doubt the big
tension of the g7
was between the uk and the eu um and
certainly between the uk and france with
emmanuel macron
um taking a very harsh stance on the
northern ireland protocol which is still
causing both sides
a really big headache currently they're
looking at the sausage horrors in which
the uk wants to extend the grace period
that it can be shipping chilled meats
including sausages um
from graper into northern ireland
without having to go through rigorous
checks
you know both sides need to take a much
more pragmatic approach here because in
a few years time the assembly gets a
vote
and if the protocol isn't working then
we could be in for a much bigger
headache than the one we're experiencing
now
but i don't think we're quite there yet
when they're willing to come to the
resolutions that they're going to have
to uh
i think lighten up on both sides uh in
order to get something done
uh jonathan boris johnson said that it
was a it was a very small
um distraction and it really wasn't
that big of a deal would you agree with
that
well according to reports it occupied
about two-thirds of the the meeting time
in the sidelines of the main conference
and clearly
what could have been an opportunity to
showcase britain's sort of global
britain if you like
uh kind of brings the confidence on the
world stage its progress
uh innovation has descended into open
acrimony uh with uh the prime minister
uh threatening a trade war uh against
half the guests
and sort of macro uh lining up to
denounce the prime minister effectively
uh in extraordinary uh language um for a
diplomatic summit
uh so you know he shows open content i'm
prime minister
uh in you know the language that he
doesn't reserve you know he doesn't use
the
other world leaders you know he would
say courteous to trump for example so i
think it shows
a kind of britain isolated on the world
stage um something
a trade deal which was meant to have
been done brexit was meant to have been
done
is now completely uh dominating uh the
european agenda
uh we were told thank you it was the
problem right
he signed up this agreement and now he's
trying to run out of time
we've run out of time thank you so much
we shall see you both in the next hour
you can talk again then thank you